se connecter à sa boîte mail envoyé un
sms utiliser son ordinateur ses gestes
qui font partie de notre quotidien ne
sont pas forcément évident pour tous du
19 au 30 avril le digi trucks propose
des formations gratuites au numérique à
maurepas que j'ai appris c'est que
beaucoup de choses et surtout un
professeur des professeurs nous aider
avec beaucoup de patience très bien
parce que même si on a quelques notions
premièrement ya toujours des tabacs très
vite les mises à jour se trouveront
panique ce camion itinérant anime des
ateliers de 1h30 à trois heures pour
aider les participants à se familiariser
au digital
là par exemple aujourd'hui c'était ce
matin c'était créer et envoyer des
emails cet après midi c'est la recherche
internet et en fin de journée on a vu
les applications on s'adapte aussi par
contre cet après midi comme j'ai dit le
programme on a aussi pas mal de
personnes qui pouvaient pas venir ce
matin pour la boîte mail du coup on a
refait ce qu'on a vu ce matin il n'y a
pas de soucis quoi on s'adapte au total
une centaine de participants ont pu
bénéficier de ses conseils personnalisés
dans la commune une initiative de
l'entreprise de télécommunications
huawei l'objectif de cette étude tracks
c'est vraiment amener la formation dans
les quartiers en fait occupé vais donc
les quartiers critères des villes ça
fait déjà quelques jours que le digitroc
est installé à maurepas et on se rend
compte qu'il ya vraiment une utilité
sociale parce que je le rappelle c'est
quand même 17 % de la population qui est
quand même concernés en france contre
lille électro nisme comme on dit
d'autres ateliers peuvent aussi être
organisée en fonction de la demande
comme être en forme son cv ou se
familiariser avec d'octo libre prochaine
étape dans les yvelines poissy du 27
juin au 9 juillet